guys good morning
happy oh god happy easter today i don't
have coffee i have a smoothie because
i'm trying to stop drinking coffee
but i always fail so i kind of stop
telling you guys when i tried
okay so today
i've had some people ask me my thoughts
and opinions on church and religion
and my thoughts and feelings on church
and religion like don't even make sense
so i've kind of held off on doing it
but i'll give you a little bit of my
religious background so
i did 12 years of catholic school so
pre-k to senior year of high school i
went to catholic school i loved catholic
school i would send my kids to catholic
school
i'm not with that oh like
the kids are worse like they're more
crazy when they're in catholic school my
experience no
we definitely were not as crazy
as our public school counterparts okay
like i didn't even drink until i was a
a senior in high school
and all the public school kids were
doing that like freshman sophomore year
so
anyways
loved catholic school so but i always
felt like
catholic church did not suit me
like i'm just kind of a wild child like
i'm just kind of out there goofy you
know whatever
and catholic is just like very rigid and
very
structured and
you know being an unstructured person
you just kind of want to rebel against
it
and i never was like you know super
crazy with rebelling or anything but
when i went to college like i remember
my freshman year i went to church
a couple times that year
and
my then throughout college i tried a lot
of different churches so i tried um
like i did the catholic church thing and
i was kind of like okay i want to
look at other options see if i like any
of those better went to a bunch of
different christian churches
um i don't know i just didn't
love any of them so anyways i get out of
college at school
and i graduate college and i just said
i'm really going to hunker down and
figure out like what i believe when it
comes to religion because
in college i just didn't have the time
like i was
a three sport college athlete i was
you know barely holding my head above
water i just
i did the best i could
so um
i was trying to figure out like what
church i liked and i decided
that
um
basically i was gonna i felt like if i
was god okay
i would make
the countries that follow me do better
like it just this in my mind made sense
to me i don't know
and
so i was like the countries around the
world that seem to do best are
judeo-christians so i'm going to rule
out all the muslim countries all of that
because
like girls just got to drive there and
like
i mean i know i joke about giving back
our rights but i don't mean it like it's
a joke
um anyways so i narrowed it down i was
like okay i'm either some form of
christianity i'm either catholic
or
um jewish so
the reason i ruled out jewish wasn't a
good reason i'm gonna be honest i
actually felt like i believed the most
of the jewish people but when i they
said all the [ __ ] i had to do to convert
nayski and i found out
i could still get into heaven if the
jewish people do good i think according
to ben shapiro in one of his interviews
i was like all right
cooked
next one i did
was then i was like okay
basically i'm either gonna pick a form
of protestant or i'm going to pick a
former catholic
and here here's the kicker
part of me still probably believes more
of the catholic stuff because when it
came down to it the difference in
catholicism and christianity is
when when there is
um something that people have a question
about in scripture okay
you either go to an institution or you
go read your bible what makes more sense
and to me
i'm sorry guys going to an institution
makes more sense because i think people
individually
misrepresent the bible all the time like
should every individual person
read their bible and come to their own
conclusions
no
but on the other hand
the catholic church has been corrupted
and can be corrupt like they're paying
for people to like
be forgiven like that's pretty bad
that's not good
so it didn't seem like either was a
perfect system okay
so
but i really loved catholic school
and i felt like that structure was good
for a kid like me i always say
if it wasn't for my parents and my
upbringing i'd be running like barefoot
topless in l.a i swear to god
trying to do music or something
um
so i ended up picking christian because
more so because i felt like i could more
consistently go to those
masses and i loved the community i lived
in milwaukee at the time
and that church i loved i lived with
some people from that church and i was
just like feeling it that was probably
the closest in my life i've ever been to
god was when i lived in milwaukee and
was going to church
so
i got baptized
because like your baptism doesn't count
when you're catholic i guess
i don't know so
um yeah i got baptized again
and
yeah it was great i loved my baptism it
was so fun
um
it was really good like spiritual
experience i don't know it was it was
great and
then
i
i'm trying to think of what else
happened
so then yeah and like that that was the
church i chose um here's the thing i
could honestly i'm so easygoing
i'd be cool raising my kids in like any
christian or catholic church i don't
know why it's just
like i don't i don't feel super strongly
one way or the other because i can
genuinely see both points of view
and i genuinely like because then my
other thought is what are the odds any
of these churches is 100 right like
someone's probably partially wrong like
do i think humans that are flawed people
got anything 100 right
no so i like church
i think church is good values like i
believe in god um
i'm really open-minded so
i don't think i'm like a die-hard like
one church is the hill i'm gonna die on
it's just
anti-feminism i'll die on that
um
but
i don't know that's my thoughts and
opinions on church
um i do
think that church
does keep women single because i think
the development of birth control changed
the game
and i don't think there's enough church
guys to only date within churches so i
think
all the girls waiting till they're
married is like gonna be hard that's
gonna be tough
um but i like the ideas and i think it's
like idealistic you know but the numbers
just don't line up and that's kind of
what bothers me about church people is
they have these ideas but their numbers
just never
really line up
so i don't know let me know in the
comments what you guys think um i think
i covered everything with my like church
history
and oh but also do i go to church here
no sorry um
i have been so busy when i got here but
i actually i'm going to a church next
week
and i was supposed to go today but i
can't leave my apartment right now
because
it's a long story basically i left my
keys and my wallet on a train
and now i'm keen walletless and i'm not
gonna leave
thousands of dollars worth of equipment
alone unlocked in my apartment naski
no sir no ma'am
so i'm watching online today but anyways
that's my opinions on church happy
easter spend some time with your family
i love you bye